et nous vous en parlions la semaine
dernière et même dans le journal d'hier
valérie pécresse président de la région
ile de france a changé plusieurs fois
d'être d'avis après avoir promis pendant
sa campagne qu'elle maintiendrait le
passé navigo à 70 euros elle a
finalement changé d'avis il ya une
semaine elle avait évoqué en l'absence
d'accord pour financer le pass à tarif
unique la possibilité d'augmenter son
tarif à 80 ou 85 euros l'augmentation a
été officialisée hier un protocole
d'accord a été signé entre l'état et
avec la région ile-de-france pour
résoudre le problème du financement du
forfait navigo après unique pour les
franciliens c'est donc une augmentation
de trois euros dès le 1er août vous
achèterez donc le passe à 73 euros qui
est cela représente une hausse de 4,2
pour cent alors est ce que vous
comprenez cette mesure c'est ce que nous
avons demandé à vous usagers regarder
bah écoutez je trouve que c'est dommage
parce que barwell ils ont bien baissé
puisque effectivement ils ont fait
1-1 tout ce en quoi tout dézoner et puis
bal à nouveau en augmentation c'est
quand on les prend tout le temps savez
on est mécontent la follia si c'est pour
apporter des financements
supplémentaires sans que c'est une bonne
chose parce que mon prix honnêtement
quand on compare par rapport aux autres
capitales dans le monde en europe je
sais qu'on n'est pas très cher
finalement bas si ces protéines et en
bon état il ya pas de problème quoi jeu
franchement si c'est pas dans la
sécurité sont au train je trouve ça que
c'est parfait c'est une bonne chose si
ça permet d'améliorer la qualité des
transports en commun si c'est juste une
une augmentation comme ça pour faire
payer plus cher notamment les plus
défavorisés
je pense que c'est complètement une
connerie